léa salamé vous êtes en ligne avec le
président du modem et maire de pau
bonjour françois bayrou
bonjour si vous étiez manuel valls
seriez-vous comme lui hier passer en
force
moi je crois qu'il y avait une majorité
possible mais évidemment vous voyez à
quel point le blocage qui vient d'être
dénoncé à l'instant des institutions en
tout cas du mode de fonctionnement de la
démocratie en france empêche que les
choses soient traités comme elles
doivent l'être c'est à dire avec raison
et en essayant de trouver le meilleur
chemin pour que les pour que change ce
qui doit changer on est vraiment devant
on est vraiment devant une situation
d'impasse et double impasse premièrement
le gouvernement n'a pas la majorité de
la politique qu'il propose et c'est en
effet une affaire de campagne électorale
et deuxièmement nous n'avons pas les
règles démocratiques qui nous permettent
de faire adopter des textes lorsqu'il ya
un large accord autour de ces textes on
est vraiment dans un l'organisation
d'une guerre de tranchées entre une
prétendue gauche et une prétendue droite
une soi disant gauche et ne soit disant
droite alors que tout ça est coupée en
deux en trois ans 4 et tout le monde le
sait et ça 7 c'est une des raisons de la
désaffection profonde que les citoyens
éprouvent rire on vous entend et ce à
des landais quoi à l'édito de thomas
legrand ce matin qui parlait de l'étape
puéril de notre démocratie
est ce que justement c'est pas le moment
de casser sa de travailler à avec les
sociaux-démocrates avec manuel valls
avec emmanuel macron avec l'aide sociale
démocrate du parti socialiste c'est pas
le moment pour vous feront travers au
dos 2-2 2-4 de renverser la table mais
dame excusez moi mais s'il ya quelqu'un
en france qui a plaidé proposer le fait
que les gens de bonne foi puissent
entendre quelle que soit l'heure
origine ou leur cheminement
c'est évidemment moi mais ceci est
absolument impossible sans la loi
martiale sa majorité nouvelle est
absolument impossible sans deux
décisions essentielles
premièrement un changement de la règle
électorale qui permettra que tous les
français soient représentés est ce que
vous vous rendez compte qu'il ya
aujourd'hui 50% des français
si vous ajoutez l'extrême droite
l'extrême gauche et le centre 50% des
français qui sont exclues de la
représentation un citoyen sur deux c'est
comme s'ils n'avaient pas le droit de
vote
et alors ceci est impossible et nous
sommes le seul pays où cette règle
existe et deuxièmement sens en retour
devant les français parce que vous ne
pouvez pas utiliser des des sparadraps
des pansements provisoire pour une
situation qui demande une refonte
profonde et donc ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire quoi en retour devant les
français ça veut dire que vous demandez
lui si jamais si jamais le président de
la république prenait la responsabilité
qui devrait être la sienne
c'est à dire de tenir la promesse
électorale qu'il avait fait d'un
changement de la règle de lectorale pour
que les français soit enfin représenté
et que les accords soit enfin possible
lorsque sur le fond on va dans le même
sens ça veut dire que lorsque ce
changement aurait été fait il faut un
retour devant les français par une
dissolution en tout cas une une choix
électoral donc ce matin vous me demandez
la proportionnelle et une dissolution
qui sait ce que vous dites je ne demande
pas la proportionnelle ce n'est pas moi
qui la demande jeudi que comme citoyen
je considère qu'il est insupportable que
50 % des français souhaitent exclus de
toute représentation et que ça nous
amène à une situation dans laquelle pour
un texte qui est un texte qui n'est pas
fondamental on soit obligé de dégainer
l'armé fatale
49 3 qu'on ne peut dégainer qu'une seule
fois par session qui est une manière de
faire plier la majorité
lorsqu'elle est en désaccord avec le
gouvernement par une petite question
personne ne peut s'accorder sur ce point
encore une petite question françois
bayrou avant de parler de la faire tapis
si vous étiez encore député aujourd'hui
est ce que vous feriez demain la motion
de censure
non je ne voterai pas la motion de
censure parce que je pense que s'il ya
un sujet sur lequel le gouvernement est
allé dans le sens donnent accord
national ont pas de manière frappante
pas en faisant une révolution ou une
refondation mais en essayant de corriger
à la marge le fait qu'on puisse pas
faire de lignes d'autocars pour que les
gens puissent se déplacer ou le fait
qu'on améliore les prud'hommes ou
l'actionnariat salarié enfin sur des
points qui sont pas négligeables mais
qui ne sont pas fondamentaux le
gouvernement a essayé d'aller dans le
sens de ce que tout le monde voit bien
être la nécessité du pays
sa majorité lui refuse et donc vraiment
je ne comprends pas pour dire la vérité
je comprends pas l'opposition qui
s'opposent à un texte qui va plutôt dans
le sens de ce qu'elle demande
habituellement
et vous voyez à quel point tout ça est
caricaturale d'une d'une situation dans
laquelle on ne peut pas retrouver les
aspirations civique qui devraient être
les nôtres
on ignorait si une petite minute pour
vous faire parler de l' affaire tapie
l'invalidation est fière de l'arbitrage
favorable à bernard tapie par la cour
d'appel de paris vous avez toujours
inlassablement dénoncé cet arbitrage en
parlant scandale d'état
même si ce n'est pas fini même si un
nouveau procès sur le fond est-ce que
vous avez l'impression est ce que vous
avez l'impression hier que votre combat
n'était pas un combat pour rien et bien
en effet ce sont des années de combat et
la décision que la cour d'appel a prise
hier est une décision sans précédent
puisque elle annule complètement
il n'en reste rien de l'arbitrage
terriblement chaud temps est voulue par
l'état à l'époque de qui donnait plus de
400 millions d'euros à monsieur tapie
alors que désormais on sait que ça
n'était pas fondée sur le fond et que ce
n'était pas légale sur la forme
et donc oui pour la première fois il y à
une suppression de cet arbitrage sans
qu'on puisse y revenir puisque je veux
vous rappeler qu'il ya un grand principe
du droit qui dit que lorsque la fraude
est prouvée dans un jugement
ce jugement est évidemment détruits
françois bayrou en un mot est bien là
cette vie doit-il rembourser l'argent il
ya ici les choses si les choses étaient
à leur place je ne sais pas où est cet
argent et vous ne le savez pas non plus
il a pris sans doute des chemins
mystérieux une partie a été bloqué par
la justice
mais vous voyez bien ce qui est terrible
et ce qui est une affaire d'état en
effet c'est que bon monsieur tapie
demandait de l'argent
c'est cette une comment dirais-je cesson
j'allais presque dire c'est son droit
métier c'est il est allé dans ce sens là
mais l'état l'état qui d'habitude se
trouve en face et qui essaie de mettre
d'obstacles à ces dérives la l'état
s'est fait complice ou peut-être
organisateurs de cette affaire c'est ça
qui est profondément choquant et contre
quoi je me suis battue en effet dès les
années avec quelques autres peu nombreux
mais qui aujourd'hui voit bien qu'ils
avaient raison merci beaucoup françois
bayrou d'avoir est avec une semaine
merci merci à france bleu